a man suspected of stabbing a jogger to
death in Washington DC is still at large
this morning police say the suspect
attacked 35 year-old Wendy Martinez in
her Northwest neighborhood
Tuesday night surveillance footage
captured the unidentified assailant near
the scene of the crime
chip Reid is on the street where the
deadly stabbing took place chip good
morning well good morning EC police say
Wendy Martinez was jogging right here
Tuesday night at about 8:00 p.m. when
she was attacked by a man with a knife
they say she ran into this restaurant
behind me desperately looking for
someone to help run this is one of those
types of unsettling incidents that
sometimes happen in large cities DC
Police Chief Peter Newsom said the
attack on 35 year old Wendy Martinez was
likely random what the motive was we
don't know the best thing that we can do
right now is identify the person that's
responsible police are looking for this
man who was seen wearing a long mustard
colored shirt dark sweatpants and
light-colored sandals they recovered a
knife near the crime scene
Martinez rushed inside this Asian
American restaurant pleading for help
manager Tommy wow showed us this
surveillance video of the incident
Martinez was bleeding profusely from her
neck before collapsing patrons rushed to
her aid they tried to prevent provide
medical assistance to her unfortunately
she was taken to a local hospital where
she was pronounced dead Martinez was an
avid runner and chief of staff for
fiscal note a technology and management
company her family said she became
engaged just last week and was excited
to be planning her wedding she was a
devout Christian a wonderful friend and
a driven professional her family wrote
in a statement everything you hope that
a daughter and a friend could be news of
the incident has this normally low-crime
neighborhood of Washington DC on edge I
really hope they catch whoever did this
police say there was only one assailant
and there's a 25-thousand dollar reward
for information leading to arrests Nora
a really sad story deeply affecting this
neighborhood as you can see dozens of
people have already left flowers
was so upset when I heard about this
chip thank you